[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar navigate the technology
landscape and predictive genomics an
introduction to key technology concepts
and strategies
i am matt ashton of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermal fissure scientific
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation you may also want to submit
any technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
dr anu matal senior staff scientist
bioinformatics
at thermo fisher scientific anew
you may now begin your presentation
thank you mike for the introduction
hello everyone um welcome to this
overview of genome white sequencing and
genotyping strategies for predictive
genomes research
we are entering the field of predictive
genomics in a big way
so predictive genomics involves using an
individual's genetic profile to predict
the disease risk and understand drug
response in order to improve the future
of
the future of health outcomes and
managed costs
in this webinar we'll introduce three
key technologies
whole genome sequencing low pass
sequencing and genome-wide active
microarrays
all the three technologies are used in
predictive genomics research and offer
very complementary capabilities
we will explore how these technologies
can be integrated together across
various applications of predictive
genomics research
we'll start with a quick overview of
whole genome sequencing low pass
sequencing and microarrays
then i'll go through key considerations
for the predictive genomics applications
and discuss how each technology can be
used to meet one's scientific needs
at the end of this deck there are also
some useful links that provide
supplemental information we also have
some technical
terms and definitions in the end
so we'll start with an overview of the
three technologies
let's first review the next gen
sequencing first
so both whole genome sequencing and low
pass sequencing are based on shotgun
sequencing
the entire genome is broken up into
small fragments of dna as shown in the
left panel
these fragments are then sequenced and
then assembled together using a
reference genome
as shown in the right panel there may be
multiple reads that align to the same
region of the reference sequence while
other regions may not have any reads at
all
there are four factors to consider when
planning a next-gen sequencing
experiment
the cost per sample
the sequencing reads per sample
the accuracy of
calls based on the research goal
and then the sample throughput
the whole genome sequencing is typically
done at a very high coverage of over 20
x between 20 to 30 x meaning that every
loci in a genome you get the uh on an
average has 20 weeks and with 20 leads
you can reliably make a call
the level of coverage can be adjusted by
multiplexing samples so if more samples
are multiplexed together then each
sample will receive fewer sequence reads
and this will in turn impact the
genotyping accuracy
as you can see from the illustration on
the left the low coverage sequencing
reads are shown in pink so the regions
have fewer overlapping reads and there
are also gaps in sequence
where there are no reads present
so multiplexing does reduce the cost per
sample and increases the sample
throughput but it does that at the
expense of genotyping accuracy
the fewer reads will impact the
confidence of making the genotyping
calls and can result in false positive
or false negative calls
the low pass sequencing is uh performed
at coverage between 0.1 x and 4x
and predictive genomics applications are
typically carried out between 0.5 x and
1 x
so the experiment starts with
multiplexing hundreds of samples
together on a single flow cell
followed by a sequencing at 0.5 x to 1 x
then the reads are aligned to the
reference genome and variant calling is
performed to get the genotype
likelihoods
then the mutation is carried out
to refine the genotype calls and impute
the missing genotypes
so in the end all all you get are
imputed genotypes and no direct
genotypes
so imputation has reasonable power for
common and low frequency variants but
not for rare variants
so a red variants are challenging to
impute and most
more often
the red variants are missing from the
reference panels and they will not be
genotyped at all
so different applications may require
different depths of coverage
in this graphic i'm showing on one end
lps where you multiplex a lot of samples
to achieve coverage between 0.1 x and 4x
this results in low cost per sample but
at the price of genotyping quality
on the other end of the spectrum you
have deep whole genome sequencing at 20
x coverage
you get very high confidence
stereotyping calls but at the cost but
the cost per sample is high
i will discuss axiom microarrays in the
next slide but as shown in the table
below the cost of access microarrays
falls somewhere between 0.5 x to 1 x
so the third technology in our
introduction is microarrays
this is not the sequencing technology
instead it uses hybridization
so the glass surface of microarray is
divided into
square features
each of which contains many copies of
specific dna probe sequence
as shown in the first graphic the
different features have different probes
represented in blue and green probes in
the adjacent features
as shown in the second graphic the probe
sequences
are carefully designed to hybridize a
specific target sequence containing the
genetic variant that exists in the
population
probes are designed for each allele of a
gradient and microarray is able to
capture either or both at least if they
are present in a sample
so once the samples are a sample has
been hybridized dna is fluorescently
labeled and then scanned by the laser
and the fluorescent signal confirms
which alien is present at which target
locus
this light highlights uh the axiom
microarray design
capabilities what differentiates exam
microarrays is the content customization
to meet diverse research needs
so with the help of proprietary array
design and data analysis
axiom
algorithms
can address even the most difficult and
great markers
we have imputation design pipeline that
can optimally select markers from
next-gen sequencing data to provide
high accuracy and coverage for the
population of interest
we also have a proprietary database of
11 million markers that have been wet
lab tested and this ensures very high
quality with small
space we also offer a modular design
where customers can start from our
catalog pre-made arrays or customize
the appropriate content representing
their target population
so in terms of genotyping accuracy uh
acid microarrays have shown to deliver
high genome-wide accuracy as well as
very uh accurate genotypes of specific
variants
and that in a very cost effective manner
so the jiva's backbone on population
arrays comprises of very highly
informative markers which are selected
by taking into account ld patterns in a
population
to achieve very high imputation coverage
in the population of interest
in addition to the high genome wide
accuracy
axiom arrays also show high accuracy of
calling specific variants
so using specialized algorithms and
probe design capabilities we can
accurately genotype
complex yet important variants
um we've shown that axiom arrays deliver
very high positive predictive value for
rare variants with a leaf frequency less
than one percent
then we can also address
complex genomic regions such as
pharmacogenes that suffer from high
homology frequent copy number changes
and low sequence complexity
um finally um axiom areas also show high
accuracy for genotyping indels as well
as copy number variations which are
usually difficult to genotype using
next-gen sequencing applications
now that we have looked at each of the
technologies let's compare them side by
side
whole genome sequencing prioritizes data
quality at the expense of high cost per
sample and look sample throughput it's a
very powerful
uh
tool for de novo variant discovery
across the entire map range and the
genotypes can be called directly from
the sequence data for common low
frequency as well as red variants
however the data analysis for whole
genome sequencing is quite complex
low pass sequencing on the other hand
prioritizes
lower cost per sample and high sample
throughput at the ex at the expense of
sequence data quality
so it relies on imputation for genotype
calling and as a result uh it has
reasonable power for common and low
frequency variants but not for the red
variants
um
low coverage also makes calling of
variance in regions such as high
homology and frequent copy number
changes
and
sequences with the low sequence
complexity very difficult
so low pass sequencing can only genotype
the variants that are present in the
imputation reference panel
and in addition of that
with low pass sequencing you also need
to do
data qc and alignment um as well as
imputation which requires very high
level of bioinformatics expertise
compared to next-gen sequencing
microarrays have very complementary set
of capabilities
so probe hybridization is very specific
and it enables high quality direct
genotypes for rare as well as common and
low frequency variants
and the throughput can be scaled from
less than 100 samples to hundreds and
thousands of samples
um
then
just like low pass sequencing
microarrays can be used for
genome-wide imputation of millions of
common and low frequency variants
but unlike
low pass sequencing the data analysis uh
is
much lower complexity
one disadvantage of microarrays is that
it cannot be used for denoble variant
discovery
and the selection of variants for array
design needs to be done carefully to
minimize any ascertainment bias
so
we just discussed whole genome
sequencing low pass sequencing and
microarrays offer very complementary
capabilities now
next let's see how these can be
integrated together in predictive
genomics research
so predictive genomics aims to predict a
disease risk and understand the drug
response in order to improve the
future of health outcomes and there are
three main applications of predictive
genomics
population scale genotyping for diseases
prediction through the polygenic risk
scores
then pharmacogenomics which involves
tailoring medication and dosage based on
individuals genetic profile
and finally the third is carrier
screening to understand the risk factors
for broad range of inherited
mendelian disorders
predictive genomics is going to be the
future of health care and in order to
make it mainstream it's very important
to accurately and affordably genotype
variants that are associated with
complex traits and diseases
so the next part of this presentation
we will look at each application
and challenges associated with them and
explore the technology strategies for
each of them
first let's look at the population scale
genotyping for diseases risk prediction
through polygenic risk scores
so polygenic risk scores combine the
contribution of multiple genetic loci
most commonly common variants with small
effects
and the goal is to estimate the
individual's likelihood for a disease or
a trait
the recent studies have also highlighted
the importance of rare variants in
predicting the risk for common complex
diseases
so in order to support polygenic risk or
studies
the technology should be able to support
large-scale population-wide screening at
a low cost
um unfortunately low-pass sequencing
the whole genome sequencing cannot
support it whereas both low-pass
sequencing and microarrays can support
this
then it should be also
be able to support high genome wide
accuracy across diverse populations
which all three technologies can deliver
one challenge as i mentioned is rare
variants
as the imputation of rail variants has a
limited accuracy low pass has limited
accuracy for
for polygenic risk scores calculations
that involve red variance
on the other hand uh
their variants can be accurately
genotyped by directly typing them on the
axiom arrays
next let uh let's look at
pharmacogenomics
so pharmacogenomics involves uh
tailoring the medication and dosage
based on individuals genetic profile
and for pharmacogenomics to be used in
personalized medicine
very high you know genotyping accuracy
is needed
the important pharmacogenomics genes
such as hla c2b6 these are regions with
very high
polymorphisms
they also have complex structures
and high sequence homology and are very
difficult to genotype
as i've shown
in the example below the sip2d60
it's involved in the metabolism of over
25 drugs that are on the market today
uh if you have a pathogenic variant in
this gene then it can impact the
efficacy of some of the drugs
cyp2d6 is a very complex gene and very
challenging to genotype
it has high sequence similarity with the
septude7 silver gene and undergoes copy
number variations and gene arrangements
with sip to d7
so any short read next gen sequencing
cannot deal with such complex genomic
regions
it requires very high coverage more than
20 x for accurate genotyping
so low pass sequencing
cannot accurately genotype these regions
on the other hand
uh i said my microarrays can accurately
genotype these regions
by using complex probe designs
uh
some targeted amplification and also
using advanced algorithms
so the final application we want to
discuss is carrier screening
um
where mendelian conditions are largely
caused by rare variants which are very
difficult to impute as i've mentioned
before
and
additionally the red variants are likely
to be missing from the reference panels
so the ng's error rates uh typically
vary from
point one percent to one percent
so low pass has limited sensitive
sensitivity and positive predictive
value for detecting the real variance
with frequency less than one percent
in contrast uh railways can be directly
genotyped on microarrays and can be a
genotype with high accuracy
finally our choice for the best
technology depends on multiple factors
especially the minor lead frequency we
want to genotype
then the uh
the accuracy of specific variants we
want to achieve and the bioinformatics
resources we have available
so if we consider the operational
factors we see that low pass is
affordable uh
but more costly per sample than
microarrays and it's also less scalable
so with low pass a large number of
samples must be multiplexed together to
achieve the low cost
whereas microarrays can be used to run
less than 100 to 100 thousands of
samples
then all
next-gen sequencing methods have a high
data analysis burden
uh while microwaves by comparison is
much simpler with well
data analysis tools
then if we move down to the table uh to
the genotyping needs all three
technologies can deliver high imputation
accuracy
uh low pass sequencing cannot be used to
genotype rare variants because it relies
on imputation
but
these can be directly genotyped on
microarrays
and
then on the insertion deletion variants
are also
often poorly infuted
or are excluded from the imputation
reference panels
because of the difficulty in calling
from nextgen sequencing
but they can be directly genotyped on
the arrays
then
low pass has low sensitivity for
detecting small copy number changes
which are less than 1kb
but these can be readily detected by
arrays
so that's the end of the webinar uh
here's a link for some resources that
are available from thermofisher there's
a white paper available
then there are also a few case studies
that scientists introduced on thermo
fisher predictive genomics landing page
thank you for your attention
i think you are new for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of this webinar if you have
a question you'd like to ask please do
so now just click on the ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen we'll answer as many of these
questions as we have time for
okay let's get started our first
question here is
are there any precision medicine
initiatives where microarrays have been
used
good question yeah there have been
several uh large-scale precision
medicine efforts that have used uh axiom
arrays
and uh just to mention a few um
there's a taiwan precision medicine
array where the goal is to genotype one
million taiwanese individuals
then there's fringe and study who are
using axial platform and there the goal
is to genotype 10 of their population
there's also med genome project in india
so all these studies are geared towards
managing health and prevention of
diseases in their population
and i also like to mention
the university of pittsburgh medical
center upmc uh they're using our
pharmacogenomics platform
and they're looking to offer preemptive
pharmacogenomics testing to over
uh four billion patients that are
enrolled into upmc healthcare system
okay
it's a new
uh let's move on to question two
can lps be combined with targeted panels
to address some of the challenges
related to pharmacogenomics
and rare variants
yes definitely so um
there are targeted next-gen sequencing
panels which offer small number of genes
or specific variants these can be
combined with low pass sequencing
so the targeted panels are usually run
at very high coverage
and
they can be used to address uh
pharmacogenomics and rare variants that
i mentioned are challenging with
low carbohydrate sequencing
um but the drawback is that if you
combine a low pass with the targeted
sequencing then they no longer
remain cost effective for large
population initiatives
um in addition to that the workflow also
becomes cumbersome
uh and that includes both the lab
workflow as well as the bioinformatics
analysis combining the data from um
targeted panels with the low pass
sequencing
so um i i'd like to mention that
microarrays provide a single solution
you can genotype these targeted uh
regions as well as uh
get very high genome wide accuracy
uh at the same time
thanks for now uh looking
looks like we have one more question
here
pull it up uh
how are the population arrays designed
and what imputation coverage can be
achieved
using axiom arrays
right so again a good question um so the
population arrays have a g g bus
backbone uh which is selected using our
proprietary educational marker selection
algorithm
and the markers are selected
so that they efficiently cover both
common and low frequency variation in
multiple populations
and to ensure high performance as well
as optimize
the use of space on the arrays
the markers are selected or the probe
sets are selected from a pool of our 10
million high performing experimentally
verified probe sets
um so we can leverage uh the thousand
genomes reference panel or any other
custom reference panel for the design
and we take into account the ld
architecture in all populations
simultaneously
uh to achieve equivalent imputation
power in each population
so to give some sense on reputation
coverage um that that we can achieve
so with thousand genomes reference panel
uh with roughly eight hundred thousand
markers
we expect to achieve uh imputation
accuracy of
over 93 to 95 percent for common markers
and for the low frequency markers with
the map range between one to five
percent we can achieve a coverage with
an accuracy between 80 to 90 percent
in all five continental populations in
the thousand genomes
all righty thank you again anil great
presentation and thanks for your time
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcasts
but before we go we'd also like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can also be viewed on
demand lab routes will alert you via
email when it's available for replay
we do encourage you to share that email
with all of your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event
until next time
goodbye
you